he was saying to me well how do you
handle something when you know
that the other person's premise is wrong
and you know he was pretty dug in
and i said well do you actually really
know that people think that they know
stuff all the time oh yeah don't mistake
your opinion for the truth
don't mistake what you've heard and what
you've said for the truth don't mistake
the way you've always done things for
the truth
don't mistake your perspective for the
truth
when you speak the truth what you should
do is speak the truth humbly speak the
truth from a place of humility
that's how you speak the truth because
even when you believe something and you
quote know
it's right
there is a chance and you need to open
your mind to this chance that you
are actually wrong and you didn't
understand something you didn't
understand a different perspective